even as the beautiful game enjoys the
ultimate high
we can't escape its ugly side the abuse
of england players after last year's
men's euros final exposed a nasty online
world and now the numbers back up what
we all suspected
analysis of more than two million tweets
in the first five months of last season
found that almost seven out of ten
players were abused at least once seven
percent were abused every day and half
of all of the abuse was directed at just
two percent of the players
one in 12 abusive tweets targeted things
like a player's race or gender we're
really talking about abuse raining down
on players every minute of every day 365
days a year so this is a an industrial
scale problem
and it requires industrial scale
solutions of the 10 most abused players
on twitter eight played here the most on
any one day aimed at cristiano ronaldo
on the day he rejoined this club and the
researchers say some of the tweets are
identical suggesting there might be some
coordination to these abusive attacks
former players say social media has
accelerated what's always been there
you've got to then look at what how
could they how do they use what's
available to them to be able to put out
this vile abuse and that is the social
media platforms that means the tech
companies the tech giants they all have
to look at ways that when they're
building their platforms they have to
make it safe for everybody that's using
them tweets it's that one negative tweet
that that sort of hits the most the
research focused on the men's game but
among those discussing the findings a
rising star of women's football the
growth of the women's game compounded
by our euros final win the other day
should only sort of catapult us to a new
level in terms of exposure and
visibility so i do have some concerns
that one of the ripple effects of that
may be of use what then is the answer i
feel that the technology will come in
that will
nip out these tweets because
the nasty people the abusive people the
racist people
even though they're not that many of
them by comparison they ruin it for
everyone else twitter says it's
committed to combating abuse but knows
there is work still to be done
regulation of social media is coming but
so too is another football season and
sadly with it almost certainly another
onslaught of hate greg milam sky news
manchester